breaking news overnight russia has
attacked ukraine and its people of
ending security and stability in europe
after nearly 80 years without a major
war on the continent president biden is
now vowing severe sanctions in response
and later we will hear more about what
the u.s should do
from democratic senator mark warner and
republican congressman michael mccall
first on cbs mornings
but we are going to begin with the
latest from inside ukraine in the hours
before dawn massive explosions rocked
multiple cities in the country including
the capital city of kiev ukrainian
border guards took this video of russian
armored vehicles crossing the border
from crimea the territory that russia
took back in 2014 also by force
information on casualties is still foggy
hard to come by at this hour but one
ukrainian official says more than 40
ukrainian soldiers are dead at this hour
and many more wounded air and missile
attacks have been reported across much
of the country not just in the capital
but also in and around large cities like
kharkiv in the east and odessa in the
south we are covering this historic
crisis from multiple angles and we'll
start with charlie dagetta in kiev the
seat of power for the ukrainian
government charlie what are you hearing
uh well just moments before we came on
air we heard another series of loud
explosions here in the capitol and two
fighter jets roared overhead just behind
us uh the interior minister says
ukrainian troops have been engaged in
combat on the outskirts of the capitol
claiming that forces shot down three
russian helicopters you may be looking
at that video now that we're trying to
attack a military airport
by land sea and air russia launched the
invasion of ukraine by bombing major
cities and targeting airports
it was the biggest attack by one state
on another in europe since world war ii
president putin spoke moments before the
assault began saying the country had
launched a special military operation
and its goal to demilitarize ukraine
convoys of russian tanks were seen
rolling across the borders in the north
south and east and rockets landed here
in the capital kiev
ukrainian president addressed the nation
calling on all citizens to defend the
country russia has attacked our state in
a cunning way he said in the way nazi
germany did in the second world war from
today our countries are on opposing
sides of world history
there are long lines of cars people
waiting to get fuel here in the capital
just after those explosions happened
pre-dawn it triggered a traffic jam of
people trying to flee the city
russia said it was hitting military
targets but video showed destroyed
apartment blocks and dead bodies
shocked ukrainians couldn't believe what
was happening
i'm alone at work she says where will i
run where do i go please tell me
warning sirens have blared across cities
people fleeing to bomb shelters and
leaving the capital in their thousands
ukrainian president vladimir zelinski
was still thought to be here in the
capitol this morning when he made an
emotional rallying speech saying the
people of ukraine want peace but if you
take away our freedom if you take away
our lives the lives of our children we
will defend ourselves
nate
charlie dagger and keep thank you